I I don't actually think it should be up
for debate we we live in a country where
this widespread racial disparities black
people are more likely to be
impoverished incarcerated killed by
police dying of heart disease and cancer
and that's not because there's something
wrong with black people that's because
of our policies and practices which
collectively are racism there's a line
in the book here about racial equality
sold as a slow but steady progression
forward which it sounds like you would
say it's not I think people on the right
would say but we need we should also
acknowledge should we not all of the
racial progress and improvements legally
and otherwise so what we try to do in
this book is show both so there has
indeed been been racial progress but
there's also been what I call in my work
the progression of racism so like voter
suppression policies today are much more
sophisticated than they were a century
ago just as you have you know elected
officials of color who weren't in in in
particular positions a century ago both
is happening at the same time